welcome to this special edition of
spectator tv
sponsored by the initiative for free
trade i'm andrew neal
and today we'll focus on financial and
economic sanctions and ask the question
the global sanctions really work
sanctions are often praised as an
alternative to military intervention
instead of
boots on the ground economic pressure is
applied to change a country's behavior
or to penalize those at the top of an
unsavory regime
behaving in ways of which we disapprove
but do they work there are various
sanctions against china
iran and venezuela to take just three
examples largely american inspired but
all three dictatorships
seem to be functioning well enough to
keep their authoritarian leaders
in power and their agendas still alive
yet still the west resorts and sanctions
just yesterday it was announced that the
british foreign secretary
dominic rabb is set to follow in the
steps of the united states and the
european union
by implementing sanctions against china
over the country's abuse of the uyghur
minority
including travel bans and asset freezes
against four senior officials some
called
even tougher sanctions supporters of
sanctions say they should always be
targeted and well
designed that seems to be the way
they're going
even when they are are they effective if
sanctions force rogue states and human
rights abusers
to change their ways a few would be
likely to object to them
what's the evidence that they were that
is our question tonight
and to discuss all that and more i'm
joined by a panel of four
tom tugenhat mp he's chair of the
foreign affairs select committee
dan hannon is adviser to the uk board of
trade founding president
of the initiative for free trade he's
now
a member of the house of lords taking
the tory with
maya lester qc is a barrister at brick
court chambers
and tom burgess is the investigations
correspondent for financial times he's
just uh produced
a book let me show you kleptopia by tom
burgess
it's uh it's a racing reads it's not
what you would really expect from the
financial times it's
full of great storytelling and great
insight how dirty money
is conquering the world that's our panel
if we were in a
proper meeting rather than a virtual one
i'd ask you to give them a round of
applause
but instead i'll move on and say we're
going to hear opening remarks from our
speakers about five minutes each we'll
keep it quite tight
then we're going to have some questions
to them from me
facilitating a 30-minute discussion and
then we'll open the panel to questions
from you our audience we have a very
big audience tonight so we're going to
leave plenty of time for you to ask
these questions
if you want to ask one please write it
in the text box
or email events at spectator dot co dot
uk
that's events at spectator dot co dot uk
shorter questions rather than essays
are more likely to be used now a very
special thanks to the initiative for
free trade the iaft
it's a research organization which works
to educate civil society
about the economics of trade
liberalization
it's sponsoring today's event let's kick
off let's go first to
tom cugan hat tom andrew thank you very
much
it's a pleasure to be in the spectator
offices for the first time
in a while this question about
economic warfare is one that has been
raised many times before
and the range of which it applies has
always been pretty great
from encircling cities to sowing
carthage with salt as scipio africanus
taught us
the way in which economics are being
used as a way of controlling
an enemy or indeed shaping an action is
not new
what has changed is the way in which
this has become more targeted
in the early days of economic pressure
even really up until only a few decades
ago the only way in which
a government could be triggered and
which sanctions could be applied was to
push them onto an entire state including
by definition
everybody within the boundaries of the
nation
when you look for example at the tragedy
that followed so many other sanctions
around iraq
in the uh 90s you see a period in which
the people of iraq suffered more than
their leadership
despite attempts certainly by the united
nations to make sure that they were
targeting
the leadership rather than the people
and in doing so what we saw was actually
that sanctions
almost invariably failed they made those
who were sanctioning them be seen
as the enemy not in any way as a partner
in the overthrow of a dictatorship but
now we're seeing something change
we're seeing a different way in which
sanctions are being applied
in fact going back to the idea of single
combat
between leaders this is the first time
that war has been
personalized perhaps for several hundred
years because what we're seeing with
sanctions
latest of which are being called
magnitsky sanctions after of course bill
browder's
partner in russian business who was
murdered by the putin regime
what we're seeing is sanctions targeted
on individuals we're seeing
named people connected to human rights
violations connected to
abuses of power having their interests
denied
the intention of course is pretty simple
that they won't be able to enjoy the
fruits of their ill-gotten gains they
won't be able to
shop at harrods they won't be able to
walk in st james's park
they won't be able to take in the
champs-elysees if
they are sanctioned directly and
personally
but are they really working well
we're going to find out and the reason
we're going to find out is because
they're being rolled out
even more frequently than they ever have
before we're seeing the numbers of
sanctioned individuals
rising only the other day well
okay a few months ago we heard carrie
lam the chief executive of hong kong
saying that she didn't even have a bank
account
and she had to be paid in cash because
of u.s sanctions
and after dominic raab's announcement in
the house of commons yesterday we're
presumably going to be seeing
one or two officials who won't be able
to send their children to english public
schools
or indeed to english or uk universities
perhaps we will see some of the red
princes looking elsewhere
we're really going to find out because
actually it's not just us anymore
who are using them the reality is that
the sanctions regime that we have used
has become so popular that is being used
against us
if you look recently at the decisions by
the chinese communist party
to sanction some individuals you will
see
the example that we have set is one that
is being
followed matt pottinger a good friend of
mine who was
the china director in the white house
under the trump administration has now
been
sanctioned john bolton the former
national security adviser
steve bannon and indeed their families
and others
are not only banned from traveling to
china but from doing business with china
and businesses that they advise or are
connected to are also
banned and yesterday or rather a few
days ago we saw
sanctions applying to the eu to the
united kingdom and indeed
the u.s and canada as china acted to put
sanctions on people like mr budikova
and ms lexman both meps and indeed to
dutch mps belgian and lithuanian mps and
even
a scholar in adrian zentz so we're going
to find out
exactly how they work and what influence
they have
but we're also going to find out what
holes there are
because the reality is that the nature
of finance is changing
the nature of state influence is
changing as electronic currencies
and the different ways in which you can
move money have evolved
even in the last few years so what does
this mean for our sanctions well
the venezuelans are already testing
holes in the dollar sanctions
no doubt china using alipay is going to
be testing holes
in the sanctions regimes in southeast
asia where it's beginning to roll out
more successfully
and i'm sure others will be
demonstrating that there are different
ways around
the dollar and the swift system and we
will discover what they are
so i suspect to briefly answer this
question
we're going to find out really what the
effect of sanctions are
and that they have so many holes their
influence is limited
and what they really are is a better
alternative to war
in symbolic terms even if not in real
tom thank you very much tom chuggin hat
there kicking us off
in this uh special spectator tv on
sanctions let's go now to maya leicester
qc maya
well to say that sanctions are in vogue
at the moment is a serious
understatement sanctions are now the
tool of choice for every single foreign
policy situation
you can see this just from a glance at
the newspapers
this week and bearing in mind it's only
tuesday so far we've had
the eu the us uk and canada imposing
targeted sanctions on
china for its treatment of the uyghurs
on myanmar's military
for its role in relation to the coup and
the eu
on eritrea's national security agency
for human rights abuses
in northern ethiopia we've got brand new
human rights sanctions regimes in the uk
and the eu
and a corruption regime we are told to
come so they are very much in vogue
now the most active of all sanctions
imposers
by far is the united states what the us
has done
and incredibly powerfully is to
use the dollar as a tool of economic
warfare it has harnessed the massive
global power of the dollar and what the
us has basically said
is if you want to carry on using the
dollar you play by our rules
so the u.s sanctions not only u.s
persons or people in its jurisdiction
but anyone in the world who does
business with people that the u.s has
sanctioned these so-called secondary
sanctions
and it has fined in billions of dollars
for breach of sanctions which no
authority outside the u.s has ever done
so it's really u.s sanctions that
determine the risk appetite of financial
institutions and companies the world
over and although president biden is
reviewing u.s sanctions policy
it's certainly expected that all of that
will continue now the uk
as tom tugan hat has said is very
supportive of sanctions as well
both as a member of the european union
where it was
the most active on sanctions policy by a
long margin
and now where since january uh as a
non-eu member state the uk has been
imposing its own sanctions
so why are sanctions so popular now and
the go-to
tool well first of all no one post iraq
and afghanistan has any appetite
for a war or for invasion and frankly
there aren't that many alternatives
second they look good they send a very
strong signal of disapproval
as the statement yesterday from the
foreign secretary
on china sanctions said we will continue
to stand together and
shine a spotlight on china's human
rights violations
so they show moral strength politically
with the press and with campaign groups
they're also extremely easy to impose
it's normally just government action
executive action with very very little
parliamentary oversight legislative
oversight
and outside the eu we don't even need
the agreement of any other member states
and the united nations doesn't function
much as a sanctioning
body anymore given the presence of china
and russia
on the security council the legal
thresholds are incredibly low
so on the basis of for example an
accusation in the press
or in an ngo report a mere suspicion
that somebody
is responsible for something or somebody
said they were
is enough to see them on a sanctions
list and this isn't just state actors
it's non-state actors around the world
so the result is a mass of sanctions
laws today
different laws from different
jurisdictions some
inconsistent with each other and some
indeed trying to block the effects of
each other
so do they work well certainly it's very
hard to argue with the noble aims
that tom tugan had outlined countering
human rights abuses stopping corruption
stopping oppressive dictators who could
argue with any of that
but i just want to suggest that there
are a number of problems with the way
sanctions are currently imposed and
administered
which calls into question their
effectiveness in really achieving
any of this there are three main
problems first it seems to me
there is no clear thinking about what
sanctions are actually supposed to
achieve
what would working actually mean what
are they trying to do
how are they going to do it and if they
do achieve it how are they going to be
lifted
and often it's quite hard to see the
strategy because it's never clearly
articulated sanctions instruments say
things like
in view of russia's malign activities in
light of the deteriorating human rights
situation in x country we are imposing
the following measures
so as to tom tugan rightly said targeted
sanctions that
that's lists of people and companies who
are singled out for restrictions
are supposed to solve some of this
problem but i think they are just as
problematic in terms of measuring what
they're actually trying to do
is this just signaling or are they
trying to change behavior and if they
are
how the people you don't see on
sanctions list are for example president
putin
or mohammed bin salman so for those who
are on the list that's often
people business people said to be
connected with a regime what is the
theory here how is that supposed to work
it's not actually analyzed whether these
people even have
assets in the relevant jurisdiction be
that the eu
or the uk nor whether
relevantly any pressure that they feel
is actually going to have the slightest
impact on those who are in fact
responsible
for the policies of the country in
question
or indeed any articulated path towards
lifting them
if you do x you may see sanctions on you
lifted that's something the us has done
but we have certainly not done that and
nor has the eu
secondly there seems to me no clear
thinking about what they are to be used
for
so sanctions traditionally are a foreign
policy instrument
but because i would suggest they're so
easy to use
they are now used every day for things
that have nothing to do with foreign
policy
corruption violations of human rights
narcotics trafficking
noble aims but why are sanctions the
appropriate tool
where there's a uk connection and we're
talking about money laundering
in the united kingdom there are
perfectly good law enforcement
mechanisms perhaps
not actively used but they should be it
seems to me and where they are used
there is due process there is a system
of investigation and prosecution
secondly how do asset freezing lists
stop
that kind of bad behavior certainly we
feel good about ourselves because of the
signaling effect
but what good is it actually going to do
and thirdly
it seems to me there's very little
analysis of the true cost of sanctions
and whether the supposed benefits
outweigh them
first the cost to civilian populations
yes it's true we don't do full trade
boycotts anymore
but you try telling the people of iran
syria or north korea at the moment where
there are incredibly far-reaching
sanctions regimes
that they don't impose suffering on
civilian populations they plainly do
again never very analyzed second the
cost of complying with sanctions
the mass of different laws i have
outlined
might make interesting work for the
likes of me but it's hugely costly for
industry to comply with them
and often the risks are so great
particularly when it comes to the eye
watering us
fines that banks and other companies
quite sensibly take the view that they
are simply too costly
and they will over comply they will rule
out particular countries as being
out of risk appetite altogether because
frankly it's so complicated to do
anything else
another difficulty and cost is that
there isn't really a responsive agency
who's actually there
to grant exceptions to licenses for
example to ensure that humanitarian aid
gets where it needs to get
if you ask people in the charity sector
i suspect that they would
more than support this third and finally
there is a real cost to the rule of law
because these are not seen as criminal
penalties
uh but as somehow preventative foreign
policy tools
there is no presumption of innocence
there is no requirement of proof
of these extremely serious allegations
beyond as i've said a mere suspicion
which can often be based simply on press
reports and the consequences can be
extremely severe for the individuals
involved
the courts tend to be perhaps
understandably deferential because this
is seen to be foreign policy
and frankly it doesn't seem to be a rule
of law priority area for
governments and this seems to me a
particular problem where we are
preaching the rule of law around the
world
so as tom tugan had said our example is
being followed
and it seems to me therefore crucial
that we set a good one
thank you my alyssa thank you
for that let's go now to dan hannon
thank you very much andrew do sanctions
actually work
it's a really under explored question
i'm really grateful to spectator tv for
organizing this debate i'm really proud
that ift
my think tank is involved with it ift
basically exists to make the moral case
for free trade
as a poverty buster but this question of
sanctions
is now as maya says so widespread that
we need to do some muscular thinking
about the cost-benefit analysis and
there is very little of that
i've just come the short walk from
parliament here to the spectator offices
having debated the genocide amendments
to the trade bill and in both chambers i
think it's fair to say that the focus
was on
regimes of which people disapproved
and how much they disapproved of them
rather than on the effectiveness
or otherwise of specific measures and
i suppose that's an inescapable side of
human nature
you know it's much easier it's much more
natural to respond
to horrors than it is to enter into a
quite technical discussion
of the costs and benefits of particular
sanctions
but let's ask the question what can a
country
practically do if it is
disapproving of policy in another
country
or indeed if it concludes that crimes
against humanity
in extremists are taking place right
it's it's a question we should ask more
often
you can imagine a spectrum at one end of
the spectrum
you could say there is an absolute
moral obligation always and everywhere
to intervene against genocide whatever
the cost
so we will get together an international
coalition if we can and we will send
troops into
sin kyan or arakan or whatever the
disputed area is
uh we will seek to overthrow the
venezuelan government or be defeated in
the attempt right that would be
the one extreme of the spectrum the
other extreme of the spectrum which say
you know what
there's really not much we can do we
will support a
condemnatory resolution in the u.n we
might uh
tick off an ambassador we might welcome
some refugees but there's not
really anything practically we can do
now the question that we need to face
that every democracy should be asking
itself if it wants to be
interested and engaged in international
affairs
is where is the optimum point on that
spectrum
where is the point on that line where
in a practical and achievable way
you are most likely to affect policy
change
in another country and here is
one thing that i can say with absolute
certainty generalized trade sanctions
are not the answer they are not on that
spectrum
at all they're not just useless they do
more harm than good they hurt
all the wrong people they hurt ordinary
folk in the other country and in your
own country
and if anything they prop up the regime
of which you disapprove
and drive support for the dictators and
the autocrats
now maya put it very well she said we
often adopt these measures because it
sounds good
right it's the most dangerous albeit
sadly
a wide spread sequence in politics
something must be done
oh there's something let's do that and
you can see
that that sequence has led country after
country
into policy cul-de-sacs from which they
then find it hard
to back out but the reality is that
imposing sanctions especially uh the
kind of general sanctions which as maya
says
are felt by people at large in iran
or north korea or whatever are a
blessing
for the authoritarian regimes
that run those places they drive the
kind of patriotic
angst in a population the sense of siege
that pushes people to support the
incumbent
i remember jose maria the spanish leader
telling me once that he had said to
castro
to fidel castro the late fidel castro
without the us blockade
your regime would have fallen at the
same time that all of the other
communist regimes fell
in 1989 1990 and as aznar tells the
story castro said yep
you know that's that's a pretty fair
analysis
now the truth is that
cubans are poor because of a rotten
economic system
we know that we've seen that it's a
rotten system wherever it's applied in
the world
but the embargo gave the castro clique
the excuse the alibi they needed the
reason you are suffering
all this squalor all this wretchedness
is not because
marxism is a bad economic model
but because of the terrible yankee
blockade
and that commensurate sense of being
under siege
kept communism going in cuba for a
generation after it had fallen
elsewhere by the way i think vladimir
putin is well aware of that psychology
my guess is that the reason that he
keeps provoking
quarrels with the west the reason he
keeps getting into fights
and almost inviting economic sanctions
is not because he desperately wants to
occupy a slice of georgia or whatever it
is
it's because keeping the russian people
in that state of anxiety of wounded
patriotism
of literally siege mentality is exactly
the condition that will make them most
likely
to support a regime like his and of
course even a dictator needs
some measure of genuine support in the
population
in extremis you have a situation like
that
in iraq in the 90s where in fact the
sanctions
for all of the attempts of the people
imposing them to target them at people
that they didn't like
ended up falling hardest on ordinary
iraqis but enriching
cronies of the regime and their allies
abroad through
the oil for food boondoggles and
associated schemes that allowed
politically connected
individuals to do well in fact when a
country is sanctioned it kind of joins a
club
with cuba and russia and so on they kind
of get together and individuals within
those countries
are then able to exploit opportunities
that are created that are always created
when you narrow a market
the one way of allowing people to get
very rich is to create
an artificial monopoly and trade
sanctions that have that have that
effect
are no different from any other kind of
monopoly
if all of this sounds uh a little bit
distant let me in a very mild form
ask the many people who are watching
tonight what their immediate reaction
was
when they heard that the uk might be the
target
of uh a specific and targeted
export ban from the european union my
my general supposition is that most
people will have responded whether you
know whether they voted remain
or leave wherever they stood with a
feeling of
wounded patriotism and some annoyance
at the other uh country for being
provocative in this way why assume
that iranians or venezuelans or cubans
feel
any differently so if not
general sanctions what well the one
thing that i think
the three of us have so who have so far
spoken agree on is that it needs to be
targeted
right we we need uh micro targeted
sanctions
but then there's another spectrum right
if you're going down the magnitsky route
or you're going down the route
uh the dominic raab outlined with the
first four officials to be targeted in
china
what sanctions do you apply even at an
individual level and again
you have to imagine a spectrum there are
we talking travel bans
are we talking asset seizures are we
talking
international arrest warrants are we at
the extreme end of that line
talking about eichmann-style judicial
kidnappings that will allow people to be
put
on trial we need to ask this question
what is it that people are most scared
of what is it that people
really do not want to happen to them and
we then need
to calibrate our policy accordingly
i think i've had my five minutes and i
don't want to eat into any more time so
let me
just finish with a general observation
that when you are trying
to reach particular individuals in key
positions and to influence their
behavior so to
arrange the incentives and disincentives
around them that they will behave better
you need to be very smart you need to
use
intelligence you need to use
eavesdropping and you need to have
a wide array of options open to you
that will result in that behavioral
change the one thing which is
absolutely clear is that we need to
approach this issue
as keyhole surgery rather than
hacking blindly around us with a cleaver
okay dan handling thank you very much
let's go now to tom burgess tom
thanks andrew absolutely delight to be
with you all um i if you don't mind i
was going to discard my notes actually
and pick up on something that maya said
um which i thought was so important that
we
we use sanctions when we should be using
the law
um and if i may i'll just give you a
story quickly of two billionaires
that i've covered and chased around
various hot parts of the world
uh one called benny steinmetz and one
called dan gertler
um bernie steinmetz franco israeli
he he got hold of an enormous iron ore
deposit in guinea in west africa
um and uh in doing so it's not been
found
he um he paid some bribes and
he he engaged in the corruption that has
been so ruinous in west africa
now about seven years later he's been
convicted in switzerland
um on corruption charges and it's been
the most um enormous
international law enforcement effort um
israeli law enforcement swiss
um and the americans chiefly um
working extraordinarily imagined
imaginative ways there was a there was a
wiretap at a florida
airport and and so on and and after
seven or so years
um the rule of law prevailed and simon
has been convicted now
whether he actually goes to jail he's
he's appealing he's always denied wrong
wrongdoing nonetheless that is that is
clearly a victory for the rule of law
now the other uh billionaire
is dan gertler who who operates a little
bit to the to the south
in democratic republic of congo one of
the most
naturally rich but utterly benighted
places um you could ever set foot
um gertler has had a long presence there
going back to the terrible war in the
90s and he's become very very close to
the dictator
uh joseph cabillo um and
gertler was eventually put under
magnitsky sanctions by the u.s
so not not a law enforcement move a
sanctions move tom tugen
mentioned earlier the magnitsky
sanctions we can course
talk more about those but gertler
although he's popped up in various legal
cases and he too says that he's never
done anything wrong
um he was put under sanctions
for the corruption he was accused of
being a part of
now one of the last things that the
trump administration did
was quietly silently in fact to
rescind essentially the sanctions
imposed on anger
after some lobbying by uh or some
awesome representations made by alan
dershowitz
um and uh reportedly by mossad
um and there you have the difference
between the rule of law and the
sanctions regime
that um steinmetz is convicted through a
legal process
and he will have to go back to court to
try to to fight that
gertler was subject to sanctions um
and he can use some of his wealth
to try to influence the process and in
secret have them
released and i think this is the central
danger of sanctions because for me
the context in which we must understand
them um
is what's going on in the world at the
moment which is an undeclared
unconventional war between states
governed by the rule of law
and aggressive expansionist
authoritarian kleptocracies
uh that tom turgan and others have done
so well to
to try to call out led by by russia and
china and i think the reason
we turn to sanctions or one reason we
turn to sanctions be interested here
what maya thinks about this
is that we have so dramatically
underfunded our law enforcement
sanctions are the easy cheap option
because
the the serious fraud office is
spectacularly underfunded to the point
that it's trying to take on
oligarchs who make its annual budget in
a fortnight last year the
the the ncaa national crime agency
received 570 000
suspicious activity reports from banks
um
which tells you two things one how on
earth is the team of 20 or so dealing
with that
supposed to actually enforce any
sanctions or any other
part of the financial regime and the
other the other part it tells you is
that banks
became aware of half a million
suspicious activities
also business transactions and and went
ahead with them
and i just made one more point if i if i
may for now
which is that um if this is a if
sanctions are one tool in a
in a war in in the new war between
the rule of law states and authoritarian
kleptocracies then
i feel we should be paying much more
attention to what's going on behind our
own lines
um the kleptocracies that are being
targeted by sanctions
if they want to turn their illegitimate
power turn their raw
autographic power into something much
more special into legitimized power
and to statesmanship what do they do
where do they come
they come to london where do they get
their private spies to chase down their
dissidents and to manipulate
western law enforcement agencies they
get them in in mayfair
who do they turn to when let's say no
sultan azerbaijav in kazakhstan when his
security forces
massacre protesters in jean ozin who
does he get to to help draft his
his speech to cross over the whole thing
he gets tony blair
um where do people with long careers
connected to russian intelligence
come to turn a little bit of their
fortunes into political influence
the conservative party that the the list
is
is long and i fear that we won't
understand um
sanctions or how they could be used
today unless we look at this whole
picture
of this fundamental struggle really to
preserve democracies
tom burgess thank you uh for that uh
let me come to tom who took in hat
uh and asked this question uh
you say tom that we don't know that
sanctions are working
but they are being rolled out ever more
frequently
would it not make sense to try and
establish if they're working
before we roll out anymore perhaps i
should have used the term working
slightly differently
we certainly know they work in terms of
signaling they work at home in the sense
that
they allow a minister to demonstrate
action uh whether or not it is action is
not entirely the point so in that sense
they do work
where they may or may not work is
whether or not they change behavior
and this is as yet unclear
and the reason it's unclear is because
we don't know
whether the son or daughter of
a an oligarch from whichever state
they may be would otherwise have sought
advantage
in the educational establishments of
germany or france or the uk
but sanctions stopped them we don't know
if that threat
actually dissuaded the oligarch or
whoever it may have been the official
from certain behavior now the reason we
don't know is because it's very
difficult to prove a negative
but it does allow what they do allow and
i say this with very caveated enthusiasm
they do allow governments to conduct
actions
that make them feel like they're acting
short of actually conducting military
action
and frankly that's not nothing you know
the idea that governments don't feel the
obligation to bomb something
i think is a positive so it's not all
negative just because it's not
immediately obvious
that what is happening isn't enormous
uh maya lester the the problem i have is
that i can see
how if you target individuals with
sanctions or individual entities with
sanctions that you can hurt them
it's possible some i suppose have been
hurt by sanctions
but it doesn't change the way
the state that they come from behaves
does it
i mean targeting individuals may be nice
to do and it may be the only thing you
can do
but it doesn't change the state policy
that you object to
or does it well i think potentially it
could
but there are a number of obstacles one
is very often as i've said the leaders
and decision makers responsible for
policy
are not those on the sanctions list no
doubt for
reasons of high politics but if you
don't sanction the decision makers it
won't be that surprising
if the decision makers don't change
their behavior secondly i think this is
quite a subtle and difficult question
because it very much depends on what is
happening in that country the dynamics
there
um who holds the power where are the
pressure points
are the leaders susceptible if the
so-called oligarchs
were in fact sanctioned in russia so if
we listen to navalny's call
for those with the serious money the
oligarchs around putin
to be sanctioned would that be enough
would that start to impose real pressure
on him
to change his policies in relation to
ukraine maybe
now i'm no policy expert but my point is
before
you start drawing up lists of
individuals an easy
and and strong signaling thing to do
this
must be something that that should be
studied what is the strategy
so is this a country where
a dictator is embedded and is simply
going to enrich themselves
find different routes to trade and avoid
any pressure
put up with his people starving or her
people starving no problem or is it a
jurisdiction where actually there are
people
who you know may complain loudly enough
that you see some movement
and i think it is often said possibly
with some force that for example
sanctions including targeted sanctions
may have led
iran to the negotiating table when it
came to the
nuclear deal now those sanctions were of
course not just targeted sanctions on
individuals although there were lots of
those they were very far-reaching
so i think a second answer to your
question is it may be true that targeted
sanctions may sometimes not be enough
but as soon as you go to broader
measures
then of course you have the broader
impact on the economy
and on the population uh that that has
been identified but
you know there are lots of studies of
the impact of targeted sanctions
you see very detailed almost econometric
tables
drawing up who's been targeted on
different sanctions regimes
what might be the aim b and when are
they effective
the difficulty is because the aims are
never articulated we never know what
they mean by effective but you get
wonderfully specific
percentages ranging from you know three
percent of the time
to 51 percent of the time they have some
impact
my point is not so much that targeted
sanctions don't work or can't work
but there is no strategy set out for how
it is they're supposed to work
and also crucially how it is that
they're to be lifted
now the us does a pretty good job it
seems to me where we don't
of engaging with people on the sanctions
list
and they are wildly better resourced
than any sanctions agency around the
world in the u.s
but they will directly engage and they
will say
the aim of sanctions is to change
behavior if you
people on the sanctions list come to us
and show us changed behavior whoever
you are we will engage with you we will
tell you
whether what you've done is enough or
not enough and if it's enough
sanctions will be lifted now that is
crucially important if you're engaging
it seems to me into targeted sanctions
because if decision makers are serious
that their purpose
is to create a behavior change whether
that is denouncing a regime as has
happened with venezuela u.s sanctions
or some other shift in behavior design a
perfect corruption compliance program
and come and show us that you mean it
there has to be an
agency resourced enough and engaging
enough with the individuals to say
no that's not enough or yes that's
enough and that seems to me to be a
decent stab
at making them work
dan hammond aren't you tilting at
windmills
by attacking the the generalized
economic
sanctions of the kind that were
implemented way back in 1960 against
cuba or against iraq
in the 1990s because that is not really
the kind of sanction
that governments are deploying in 2021
we've moved on from there
i wish that were true but i'm afraid it
isn't
the uh amendment to the
trade bill currently before parliament
says
if there is a determination of gross
human rights abuses in another country
with whom we have a trade deal the trade
deal should automatically lapse now
not having a trade deal is if you like
the softest kind of economic sanction
but it is general
it is a generalized sanction against the
whole country it isn't targeted
at individuals and i have to say that
the debate both
inside and outside parliament is still
very much along those lines so people
will say things like
well if we're having sanctions against
china or cuba
then why don't we have sanctions against
saudi arabia or israel or
they fill in with their particular hobby
horse
and the the unquestioned assumption i
think
animating a lot of this public discourse
is that sanctions are effective and that
restricting trade is a way of hurting
other people
and of course i think as all of us on
this panel of agree
it it hurts the wrong people and it also
hurts ourselves but this is a vitally
important
discussion to be having in an age where
increasingly
there is a reluctance to see the benefit
of unrestricted commerce and i don't
just mean
that there is a general protectionist
mood although there is coming out of the
epidemic and the lockdowns we see it in
in the u.s we see it in brussels we see
it in china
uh there is a i'm afraid as always
happens when there is one of these
events people get thrown back on some
rather primal instincts and they become
more protectionist more
inward-looking uh there's suddenly a
great vogue for self-sufficiency and all
the rest of it
but even setting aside the economics if
you
were to to plot a graph where you looked
at the nastiest regimes with the worst
human rights abuses
and you were to correlate that on the
other axis with
the countries that are most integrated
into the global trading system
you would see a fairly strong
correlation
between otaki and
autocracy you you'd see that as it were
at one end you have the the north koreas
and at the other end you have the
the new zealands now of course it's not
a perfect correlation of course we have
uh exceptions but as a general rule
encouraging market norms encouraging the
spread of secure property rights
arbitrated by some kind of independent
magistracy is a way of
leading countries away from
authoritarian government so
anything that if you like reverses that
direction
that pushes them back towards a more
controlled economy
is in the most direct sense
self-defeating and we should be very
careful i would say
of legislation designed to send a
message
it's the the curse of our age whether
it's trade sanctions
or hate speech bills or as soon as you
as soon as you hear a legislator
standing up and saying we need to send a
message almost
guaranteed you are going to have
disproportionate
unintended consequences because
performative legislation is bad
legislation
but should we be doing free trade deals
with the totalitarian states
yes it will make them less totalitarian
evidence for that well as i say if you
correlate the countries which are
the most economically controlled with
the ones which are the most politically
backwards it's not an exact correlation
but there is a pretty strong one but if
you want to
uh spread the kind of assumptions that
underpin
liberal democracy then spreading
property rights and consumer choice is a
good way of doing it because once people
get into the habit
of saying i can choose my mobile phone
operator
i can choose my make of car i i can
choose
whatever branded clothes it becomes much
more
anomalous that they can't choose who
their mayor is or their regional
governor and so you created but
where is the evidence for that i mean
china hasn't got a free trade
deal with the eu or with america but it
sure trades a hell of a lot with both
i mean billions and billions of dollars
worth of trade and it's grown
exponentially
since the year 2000 since it got into
the wto china has become more brutal
more repressive with more trade not less
yeah i mean china is always held up as
the the one counter example and it
shouldn't be the only country that we
look out here well saudi arabia i'll
give you another one saudi arabia well
i'm not sure that you could argue i mean
i i'm i'm really no fan of
of saudi arabia and i think we are all
together far too soft on saudi arabia
but i don't think you could argue that
saudi arabia is currently
becoming more repressive than it was uh
five or ten years ago oh i think
you can it's an area of the road i know
quite a lot about
mbs has turned an oligarchy which is how
saudi arabia was run basically into the
dictatorship of one man
yeah i mean if you if you want to uh
if you want to make the case that mbs is
a very bad thing you'll get no
argument from me the way in which he
managed to convince an awful lot of
uh westerners by pressing buttons on
women's rights in israel and so on to to
to overlook his abuses was extraordinary
but on the uh you know if you look at
if you take a like with like comparison
in south american countries in african
countries in asian countries
and you say which are the ones that are
opening most
uh allowing foreign investment uh
allowing
you know joining the wto uh allowing uh
norms of property to uh become embedded
by and large it's not a perfect system
i'm not saying it's you know i'm not
saying this is a magic wand that makes
them democracies but by and large
it helps okay and let me ask tom toughen
up the same thing
should we be seeking i mean there are so
many countries
with whom we don't have free trade deals
most of the asean
members we don't australia we don't
canada we don't the united states
uh we don't uh should we
not be concentrating on doing free trade
deals with them
rather than with dictatorships yes we
should and and you know i'm
i buy dan's uh line that there isn't a
perfect correlation but
by and large these things are lying at
least they used to
but i i have to say i think the the
change in this
correlation as it were is that uh is
china
um you know correlation is not causation
and the reality is what we've seen in
china in recent years
is a great increase in individual wealth
in
uh different forms of self-determination
in various different ways in
economic sense anyway and yet
an increasingly autocratic government
now perhaps this
is you know the supernova that's shining
brightest before the dark
but at the moment the regime of uh
general secretary xi
is clamping down on individual freedoms
at the same time
as economic freedom seems to be growing
now
let's see what that means but as far as
free trade deals
you know let's look at where we can
actually
develop partnerships because free trade
deals if they are going to serve both
parties need to be
based on principles that both parties
can agree on broadly speaking
predictable outcomes which we call
the rule of law after all the rule of
law is not something magical it's just a
way of
trying to predict the future through
certain organized
algorithmic encounters now that we
should do
with countries that least are likely to
follow the procedural
uh you know elements that we put in
place
so i think that as much as possible we
should you know
invest in free trade deals with
countries that are similarly minded
and perhaps at the very broadest level
have the sort of wto the absolutely
lowest possible standard of openness
with those we don't tom burgess let me
come
back to you because it seems to me
that when governments introduce
sanctions against individuals
oligarchs people who may have had
ill-gotten
gains and then kind of use london to
money launder the the money in to try
and make it
quote respectable when governments do
do that are they trying to get these
individuals
or surely it's a foreign policy
initiative which they're trying to get
the
regimes that these individuals represent
to change their ways
and in fact they don't change their wage
you may upset the individual you may
even get the individuals you may get an
unexplained
wealth order and so on but state policy
doesn't change does it
well i think it's a crucial question
that um and i i think it goes to the
heart of this which is
for me we we we mistake
essentially organized crime gangs that
have taken over nation states
for those nation states so i i think the
discussion about sanctions
has gone a long way from the idea of
changing
foreign policy i think the idea that we
we apply these sanctions in order
to shift let's say putin's foreign
policy
would be naive and mistaken because
to my mind putin's main reason for
capturing and maintaining power is
self-enrichment
and the enrichment of the cabal around
him and the projection of that power
through that
corrupt wealth and and therefore i think
that brings me to a point that's um
i think in defense of sanctions maybe
which is that um
what what we're trying to do is make it
difficult to be
ultra corrupt and to weaponize that
corrupt money and shift it into the
west and that means simply making it
difficult for the rulers of these
cryptocurrencies to use the banking
system
and that's something sanctions do do
they make it
more difficult more awkward to shift
your money through the banking system
it's a game of wackable right where
we might name a handful of um entities
with funny names in funny places
controlled by
oligarchs but there will be for every
one we find there'll be a dozen we know
so we're constant in this game of trying
to
catch um the the the
spot the conduits by which this corrupt
money moves out
into the rule of law states but i'd say
i just say
lastly that there are as we've been
saying throughout
massive problems with the use of
sanctions but i had two conversations
recently one with an incredibly brave
journalist um
she works in eastern ukraine you can
imagine what it's like trying to
turn to report there on especially
russian interests
and on the other hand i had another
quiet conversation in london with um
an mi6 veteran who'd done a lot of work
in russia and and china and i i put
this this essentially sort of part of
the case we're all making to
to these two people and i said look
sanctions can be
uh that they we use them when we should
concentrate on
well-resourced law enforcement and they
can be manipulated by kleptocrats to
take down their own enemies
and all the the problems we've been um
we've been listing and the journalists
in eastern ukraine said we don't have
time to wait for the seven year
law enforcement um case against some
some oligarch who's doing putin spitting
in eastern ukraine
we're we're essentially under w we're
under occupation now we need anything
you can do
to block the money flows and the mi6
chap his argument was very simple he
said
you know we are we are wide open to um
the malign influence of these
authoritarian kleptocracies
and if all you've got is a blunderbuss
by which he went sanctions
if all you've got is a blunderbuss then
use a blunderbuss
maya tom duggenheit says that uh
well-heeled lawyers and sick accountants
are
taking eye-watering fees from oligarchs
to help
get them off these blacklists is he is
he talking about you
i wish he's not talking about me and uh
for the reason that
uh if you want to represent somebody
who's on one of these lists
you need to get a license because their
funds are frozen
and if you get a license the amount of
fees that are charged
will be subject to incredible scrutiny
by the authorities
uh in in the uk at least and so the fees
are set at such a level that actually
the opposite problem is true there are
many law firms
who will never be able to represent
people on these lists
because of the levels of uh fee that
they're able to charge but also because
i'm sorry to say
that the agencies responsible for
granting licenses
takes so long to do so that by the time
those legal licenses are granted it's
simply too late for the firm to be able
to represent someone
there's another problem which is that in
the u.s for lawyers
who wish to represent those on sanctions
lists uh their law firms very often
don't
enable them to do so don't permit them
to be able to do so because of the
reputational risks
so actually i think there is a real
problem of access to justice
given how incredibly low the evidential
thresholds are for getting people onto
sanctions lists
and given that i have seen a number of
cases not only where it seems
that the evidence is very thin or even
unjustified but where there are
cases of mistaken identity where there
are simply the wrong people on the list
it's absolutely crucial to the
credibility
of these regimes that they sought out
the proper means of legal representation
in a fair way
so if you are going to engage in the
business of naming people and
shaming them that you at least permit
them the dignity of being able to
defend themselves properly
and tom chickenhead isn't that a a point
the point
uh maya made earlier was that uh
the government can put you on a
blacklist there's no appeal there's no
real due process
the government just designates you on a
black list and certain sanctions uh
will follow now in a number of cases
that they
you may have got the bad guys uh they
all
do seem to be largely guys and uh
the and so a kind of justice is done if
these people then
suffer by having their wealth or some of
it frozen
but it isn't due process is it it's
not it's not a proper rule of law it's
it's ruled by government fiat you're
absolutely right and actually our
reference to
lawyers and accountants was actually in
relation to uh money laundering
and that's in our moscow's gold report
of may 2018 not so much to do with
sanctions but to do with
uh the illegal movement of funds uh
around
uh the world and you're absolutely right
there is a big difference here and we're
talking actually about two different
things and i think it's worth
being clear there is a difference
between the aspects that
tom and maya have spoken about which are
absolutely
rule of law issues they're to do with
corruption they're to do with
uh protecting ourselves from dirty money
for example and corruption that may flow
into the uk
through various different uh avenues and
then there's
foreign policy and the two are not the
same
so when you talk about having government
by fiat
in terms of rule of law you're
absolutely right this is a challenge
that we
you know really need to look at very
seriously because if we're simply
sanctioning
individuals because of their connection
uh to others but or is all because of
the corruption that they may
be connected with that is a rule of raw
issue if however what we're doing is
we're sanctioning individuals because we
believe that the money that they're
using
is being used to for example undermine
the integrity of the state to corrupt
state officials
and directly as a national security
threat then that is a different
requirement in the same way as the
military and diplomacy comes under a
different legal
system in many ways i wouldn't overstate
this but in in some ways than
than uh than contract law and actually
it
for much of what we're talking about the
real effect the best effect
is actually not sanctions the reality of
sanctions on vladimir putin are going to
make
no difference at all he's a man who's
somehow or other collected
north of 200 billion us dollars in
various different ways
and is probably the richest person in
the entire world
the real way uh in which to expose that
is to
start to highlight exactly where those
accounts are to highlight
the different jurisdiction in which the
money is hidden and
make sure that somebody like tom burr
just writes a book
and then we give him protection because
he'd need it but writes a book
that would uh highlight every single uh
aspect of the money that he's stolen off
the russian people and many many others
around the world
because sanctions on somebody like him
don't really make a difference
tom and then to dan and then i'm going
to take some questions from the
audience kicking off with a politician
from venezuela who sent in a question
tom let me come to you first london has
built up this
reputation not in a good way over
recent years of being sort of launder
mapped laundromat for dirty money
and we've seen it pour into the property
market
and even into the public schools and
you know i hear stories of uh people
turning up with cash to pay these
massive overpriced school fees that uh
people think
they they have to pay uh it also puzzles
me as someone who's just
been opening a bank account and the
amount of due diligence i have to go
through to
to get it proof where i've lived for
years
passport notarized and persecuted all
the rest of it
how these people can get away with it
but that's another point when it's so
difficult for me just open a bank
account as someone who's
kind of reasonably well known as not a
money launderer
um but because london has become so
dependent on this
kind of economy i think the new york
times at once said said about
90 billion pounds in cash have been
spent in london in one year
to what extent are we really out to stop
this or actually
do we make a few token efforts but
overall we quite like seeing all this
money come into our capital city
yeah it's a crucial question i mean
there was that to me defining moment
in uh first half of 2013 shortly after
the annexation of crimea when
a well-placed uh photographer on downing
street
got a snap of the briefing notes going
into the national security council
the gist of which was okay we we should
impose some sort of sanction
on on on russia for for for the land
grab in crimea but whatever we do we
mustn't interfere with the interests of
the city
and that's the that's the fundamental
problem so for instance when
when the us has its huge tax clamp downs
yeah it goes after um uh
ubs and credit suisse the big swiss
banks for helping americans avoid taxes
you can see there's obviously a kind of
direct interest for the us treasury
right that's its money
being squirreled away the uk is in a
very different position where it is
this kind of entrepot right for um
for for uh corrupt money from all over
the world tom took and others have
done a great job of demonstrating this i
before we
um before we uh we started i went back
to the stats on
on global sanctions put together by this
uh great think tank in the us called
c480s
um it just it basically works out where
all the sanctioned entities in the world
are
right this is u.n u.s and eu sanctions
and
iran is way ahead and then russia and
syria are very high
um but then you come to congo
118 um venezuela 184 and just two behind
venezuela
is the uk with 182. and
i i think we we as you say we often
forget that
kleptocracy is essentially transnational
right this corruption we're talking
about
it's not linked to states sure dictators
have to capture state resources they
have to be able to
control the allocation of state
contracts the allocation of oil and
mining licenses and they have to be able
to sign
arms deals but their actual wealth is
generally here and that is the core of
our problem you fit on there
which is do we see dirty money
essentially as an investment for which
we we want to hold our nose
or do we see it as i think we should as
a fundamental threat to democracy and
that really is the
decision between those two positions i
think is is at the heart of this idea of
global britain and
what a post-brexit britain is going to
be
dan let me come to you on this is this
good news or bad news
in recent years we have taken
some targeted sanctions against
individual russians close to the kremlin
or
oligarchs whose gains we fear may be
ill-gotten
and we've done that on a number of
occasions particularly after the
uh chemical attack in salisbury but at
the same time in the past five years
our uh trade with russia has grown
rather quickly i was quite surprised of
the figures we
we imported six billion pounds worth
from russia in 2015.
it's now over 10 billion uh pounds we've
we've done
is that good or bad it's good news
because it's ordinary people in both
countries doing better
and we again we have to be absolutely
rigorous about saying we will deploy
against russian individuals or the
russian state
things that are effective things that
will change behavior
or will be regarded as deterrence
by the bad guys not things that will
look good
in tomorrow's headlines so i
you know there's no question that the
russian state uh
in salisbury for the second time uh
murdered somebody living under the
queen's peace that he's uh by some
definitions an act of war it plainly
invited a response the the easy thing
for any minister in that situation is to
say oh here's something let's impose
some sanctions
and to a degree that happened but of
course it's been ineffective
i wonder whether the better solution
isn't what tom toukenhart was just
suggesting you know the the russian
state in many ways is a slightly sort of
ram shackle entity kind of a lullaby
about like
like an alcoholic bear but one thing
that is brilliant at
is integrating diplomacy
soft power cyber warfare and where
necessary
uh hard ballistic power and
we have been left standing in that field
we we've really not
engaged with anything like the
determination
that some hostile regimes have and i
wonder whether the uk
now needs to be looking very hard at the
kind of
our equivalent uh of russia's desi
information campaigns
we know that one thing that is regarded
as a deterrent by putin and putinites
is having their wealth revealed right
that's that
was one of the sins that landed navalny
in prison
it's why they hate people like tom
writing books about them
if that's information that can be
intelligently disseminated that is
something that they definitely don't
like and the same is true
uh for some of the individuals in other
nasty regimes
i'd make one final point in this again
to agree with with tom
while doing this we should in parallel
be moving towards a much more open
liberal trading order
with the world at large including with
some of our closest friends
it's extraordinary that as eu members we
were
never able to have free trade agreements
with australia new zealand
the united states those have to be
priorities for us now
and in pursuit of them we need to be
prepared to be comprehensive
and ambitious right this is not a time
for us to say oh
well you know we're all in favor of uh
of trade but we we're going to start
prioritizing a bunch of
unrelated issues of you know
food miles or animal welfare or labor
rights those are all
important questions but they don't
belong in a trade deal we we have to be
a country that is leading the uh
the effort to restart a stalled global
trading system as we come out of these
uh lockdown recessions and i learned
today that you've done
this initiative for free trade has uh
announced an association with the
university of buckingham to
contribute to the teaching and research
on trade policy
well somebody somebody has to teach
trade policy from a free market point of
view it's
it's a surprising surprisingly big niche
or
an awful lot of academic trade is taught
by people who
want to talk about everything except the
trade they want to talk about
protection of rare species or women's
rights or whatever but
trade is actually a separate subject
from those things it shouldn't take too
long to teach them that then all they
have to do is
start with adam smith and move to
ricardo and it's pretty much job done
yeah let me bring in some questions now
um from our audience i'm going to put
two together
because they they overlap um
professor tim evans has a very uh clear
question which is what do you make of
recent reports concerning
the illicit trade involving gold and oil
between venezuela
and the uae as the united arab emirates
uh on the gulf
and i linked that with a question that
we've heard from julio borges who is a
venezuelan
opposition politician he's co-founder of
the justice first
political party he says as an opposition
politician in venezuela we're a country
living under sanctions i've watched a
regime impoverish their people abuse the
most basic human rights
but they continue to live lavishly as
a result of sophisticated sanctions
busting
with the help of a number of regimes who
are set to undermine
humanitarian values in the rule-based
order
the current regime in venezuela smuggles
our national gold
reserves out in return for cash
and refined oil products and he talks
about a reuters report i assume
professor evans
is doing the same thing russia moves out
venezuelan gold reserves
iran provides gasoline additives as well
in the ua
e provides cash for the gold ah
pretty complicated tom took in half but
it shows you how you can
run these sanctions if you've got state
actors in particular
willing to get around them and i have a
point out that the uae
is meant to be one of our most important
allies in the gulf
well it's certainly true that state
actors can get around pretty much
anything the best
dodgy dollar notes are printed by north
korea
and so uh there are a whole series of
different ways in which
state actors are fraudulently
undermining different
uh procedures so uh you know all i can
say is yes
um the reality however is that there are
actions
uh you know the the actions against
these things are very difficult short of
war and so the reality is
if you want to stop them the only way
realistically to do them is to expose
them
now you know we run very advanced forms
of intelligence gathering networks and
we are able in various different ways
to know who is doing what to whom and
when
and this is where my faith in the
sanctions regime is not always
that high but my faith in social
pressure
peer pressure after all we are social
animals is rather higher
being exposed as somebody who's willing
uh
to watch the destruction of venezuela or
willing to enrich themselves
on the death of russian children or
whatever it happens to be
this time is i think greater deterrent
to most people
than the possibility that you may not be
able to shop in harrods for a few months
let me go to henry uh he doesn't give us
his uh surname but he asks
but oversight for sanction
implementation exists
that prevents economic warfare
escalating into
war maya i guess there's really nothing
that could stop that happening but it
tends
not to to happen in the modern world is
that right
well i think that's right so economic
sanctions traditionally
were accompaniments to war uh and it's
only
relatively recently a 20th century
invention that they are used in peace
time as an alternative to war
but obviously i mean iraq is a case in
point where sort of sanctions are tried
and warfare may follow and there's
certainly nothing stopping that that's a
pure a pure matter of policy
uh just one comment on the last question
um i mean there's certainly reuters
reports to the effect
of sanctions evasion in relation to
venezuela
but here's where my point is absolutely
crucial about proper enforcement of
sanctions so part of do global sanctions
work
is is anyone policing whether they are
working
or being avoided and here again the us
is the world leader there are every day
reports of criminal prosecutions and
settlements reached
for people said to be evading u.s
sanctions
that's not been a feature of eu or so
far
uk sanctions very much but we'll see but
that
the the stick element of imposing fines
and criminal prosecutions for breach
is of course one element that's really
important to the efficacy of sanctions
tom burgess it seems that america the eu
the united kingdom we're
we're we're prepared to hurt but not
necessarily to wound very
deeply so we go for some of the
oligarchs
in russia we've gone this week for some
high-profile
people in china but of course we don't
go for mr putin
we don't go for president z in china
and here is if if the uae i i don't know
but if the uae
is guilty of trying to uh break the
venezuelan sanctions by helping
with the gold purchases well of course
the uee
currency is pegged to the dollar and
it's entirely
uh meshed in with the u.s banking system
and dollar denominated
assets but i suggest the americans ain't
gonna go
for uh the uae's leadership either
yeah i think i think there is this
enormous difference maya's right to say
the u.s has as a sort of ferocious
enforcement mechanism
vastly more effective than anyone else
but that there is this central
contradiction that
that all these sanctions are ultimately
political decisions
and they're not law enforcement tools
and so they don't have they don't come
with
um prosecutorial decisions these are not
uh you know career prosecutors of the
department of justice
or the swedish fraud officer or whatever
deciding that there's a case
to be brought and um pursuing it with
all their
um with all their
their vigor um and i guess there's also
again this conflation of
um gangsters and presidents right we
putin is at once the president of a
estate
that's a member of the united nations
and the leader of a kind of gangster
cabal
and the sanctions deal with one and on
the other hand we have to deal with him
um deal with his
his office i just i'd had one other
point on this this um
it's linked to the venezuela question as
well which is
you know look at that list of countries
that are suspected they're named in the
reuters reports there's been other
investigations some some evidence that
i've seen
that does seem to flesh out these
smuggling routes
these sanctions busting routes of
venezuela and gold especially
through western central africa and into
abu dhabi and um abetted by by russians
and perhaps
in exchange for petroleum products from
from iran you know look at that look at
that list
and then i if i may just read you this
quote that
sergey lavrov said yesterday in china he
said we need to reduce sanctions risks
by bolstering our technological
independence he's saying this
standing next to his chinese counterpart
by switching to payments in our national
currencies and global currencies that
serve as an alternative to the dollar
we need to move away from using
international payment systems controlled
by the west so
by enforcing sanctions so zealously
which is obviously tempting and there
can be very good reasons to do that
you're in danger of creating a war on
drugs problem which is that you make the
black market so huge that it becomes
almost bigger than the illicit
market and you create um entire
economies outside
the rule of law dan hannon peter keatley
uh
asked a question he's he says even if
sanctions are not
very effective and we've gone through
some of the reasons why they might not
be tonight
either the generalized ones or the more
specific targeted ones
which you remain more fashionable he
says even they're not very effective
are they not better than nothing no
they're worse than nothing
they they are not even the targeted ones
um
some very specific diplomatic measures
against individuals may be very useful
and uh and if they're very micro
targeted they can be useful yes um
but the the the the kinds of sanctions
that we're talking about say in
venezuela
i think are a good example of how you
actually
exacerbate the problem and i'd like if i
may just to come back for a second to
that question
um not least because both of the the the
questioners
are very distinguished people i know
them both and it's great that you have
quality as well as quantity in this uh
in this
audience as the spectator dan i don't
think
where else so but but venezuela i think
is a very
neat case in point first of all they
the the sanctions were already being
used pretty much
uh globally by chavista uh fellow
travelers
and enthusiasts before they'd been
applied
so when the when the venus venezuelan
economy began to collapse once the spike
in oil
was passed the the go-to excuse for
every marxist sympathizer in every
british university in the left bank in
all over the world was oh this is a kind
of you know uh
cia uh hit job you know sabotage
sanctions all the
at that stage there were almost no
i think there may have been some
restrictions on buying venezuelan
government debt but that was it right
and
again it's a slightly odd thing if you
you know if i were
if i were a cia operative and my job
were to
sabotage the venezuelan economy what
would i do i mean you know i turn up and
i open my laptop it
it's actually remarkably difficult right
as we've seen you began the whole the
whole debate by saying
we've had sanctions for years in some of
these places and they're doing very well
but as as the the questioners
correctly imply with the
example they give about the illicit
trade in gold and
petroleum what happens
when you are a sanctioned country is you
kind of join this club
a pretty unappealing club with russia
and iran and all the rest of it
but they kind of close ranks and they
create what tom
burgess just ably called a a big global
black market that is operating outside
all of the normal methods and laws
of global trade and so the one thing we
know about operating in that black black
market
is that it doesn't benefit any ordinary
people because it's a
an illicit kind of cartel
it's just like the drugs trade you are
gonna you're gonna create fortunes
for a few connected individuals
cronies of the regime and their families
but you're not gonna have
any benefit for the wider population and
that in a nutshell
is why sanctions are worse than useless
free trade is a way of lifting ordinary
people
ending poverty spreading the benefits
sanctions or any other trade
restrictions
tend to funnel the benefits and hurt the
wrong people
do you agree with dan and that sanctions
he's obviously against the generalized
ones but he seems also to be against
most of the targeted ones he says they
could only really work at the margins
do you agree with that well i think
there's certainly a role for some
sanctions as i say in protecting
ourselves i mean
the flow of dirty money through the uk
whether that's
uh you know buying property or as you
raised it
paying for educational various other
things can corrupt
our own systems can undermine uh our our
own democracy and can
weaken our own defense so i think
there's certainly an element of
sanctions
there but i'd see that more as national
security related
but in terms of actually changing state
policy i mean it's quite clear that you
know sanctioning one of the richest men
in china chairman xi
he's not going to change chinese state
policy significantly nor would
sanctioning president putin in russia
and so there i think that uh he's got a
very
good point which is you know as dan says
you know handing control of an economic
of economic levers
to fewer and fewer people is guaranteed
to result in one thing which is the
greater enrichment of those few
and it will look even if it's not the
reality it will look
as though those sanctioning are simply
doing it in order to
empower those few and so it's
it's certainly something that one should
be extremely cautious of
actually i'd add one category where i
think
sanctions are valid and that is uh for
example in the case of china if you have
a prohibition
on slave-made produce
that it seems to me is a a legitimate
and
proportionate way of uh
uh of trying to reduce a barbarity in
another country
maya lester is it
the function of sanctions i mean tom
took it hat is mentioning
two things really there about sanctions
what one
is as a tool of foreign policy and the
second is
to try and clean up the laundromat
reputation of london and its own viral
do we have evidence that sanctions have
worked in either case
now i think as i said in my opening
remarks it's really dangerous to
conflate sanctions
with law enforcement or even with
national security
so the problem that another a number of
panelists have rightly identified is the
problem of dirty money as it were being
able to circulate too freely
in london and you made the point that
you know
is actually fighting financial crime in
london
a priority area or do we actually quite
like the funds in london i think this is
a really serious issue because
serious fraud is not very actively
prosecuted in the united kingdom
and obviously should be is there we ask
ourselves a lack of government desire to
do so is it a problem of
underfunding as tom burgess suggests
interesting problem but i think it's
certainly a problem however
what is very problematic is using
sanctions where we should be using law
enforcement now clearly
this is for only for cases where we can
use law enforcement
and that's basically where there is a uk
connection so we're talking about the
problem in the united kingdom
the problem it seems to me with using
sanctions by which we mean
basically asset freezes and travel bans
there are several problems first of all
the standards drop immediately we're not
talking any more about criminal trials
with proper standards
standards of evidence we're talking
about a much lower threshold which
creates serious problems where we're
setting an example to the rest of the
world but the other problem is where
does it end if we start putting people
on sanctions lists these are non-state
actors because they've done something
wrong
and that is opened up beyond the uk
we're going to be in the business where
we have a never-ending
you know people that we regard as bad
being sanctioned by the united kingdom
on the basis of very low thresholds of
evidence and that i think is not a place
we want to get to i want to just make a
couple of very brief
points first of all i didn't wish to
suggest
that sanctions don't ever work the main
point i want to make is that we don't
analyze whether they work in advance
very effectively and we don't have a
clear strategy for determining
how it is that they're supposed to work
but i do think it's significant
and we know this that president putin is
bothered by sanctions
we also know that china is bothered by
sanctions which is exactly why we have
the statement
that tom burgess referred to where you
know we get counter sanctions but also
will should we start getting less
dependent on the dollar
now it seems to me that you know when
people are bashing president trump's
uh door down to try to get sanctions
lifted that must be because in some
sense they are hurting
and i think you know sanctions on russia
much maligned
there is to some extent of strategy
which is if we place sufficient pressure
on the state-owned banks and financial
institutions
that will cost the state dear but so
what we don't have is a very clear
analysis
of how are they supposed to work and are
they working
and indeed as today has clearly
highlighted the relationship with trade
policy and that also needs studying
and just finally i also don't want to
give the impression that we're in a due
process black hole
so it's definitely not the case that
people are just added to lists with no
due process at all
that used to be the case and post 911
alleged terrorists were rounded up and
put on
um financial sanctions lists with
literally no reasons given now
the uk's new sanctions legal framework
does have a process for judicial
challenge for evidence being released
and so on
but it's a process which is appropriate
to the sort of foreign policy framework
and not i think one that's appropriate
given
the very very significant impact that it
can have
on those who are subject to sanctions
finally just a quick correction dan
gertler still is subject to u.s
sanctions what happened was he had a
license granted him by the u.s
authorities for a year to be able to
do certain things with his funds and it
was that license that was revoked
but he is still very much subject to
sanctions in the united states
tom i see you want to come back there
tom well but just on that point i mean
that's why i said he
the sanctions were effectively relaxed
yeah i agree that he is still
technically subject to magnitsky
sanctions but he only needed a license
for one day to move all his money out of
the u.s
and the biden administration i believe
has now reim
revoked that license but um
in in real terms what happened was
through um clandestine
uh lobbying efforts gertler
was freed from the effect of those
sanctions for a
period of time and that the big worry
was that was
long enough for him to do whatever he
did with any
assets that may have been frozen well so
this again highlights just
another problem i want to reiterate i
won't say anything about the specifics
of
of of that case but what i will say
is you contrast the case of someone
who's added to a sanctions list
with someone who's subject to a criminal
process and prosecution
and the truth is if someone is added to
a sanctions list
and they strongly deny what is said
against them
uh then um you know they can be added to
a sanctions list
and journalists and anyone around the
world uh and the public at large will
think that what is said about them is
correct it has an incredibly
far-reaching effect on reputation
and my point is that is not something
that should be encouraged
where when you're making allegations as
serious as grand corruption
somebody is normally entitled to full
due process of law
all right we're coming to the end now of
our discussion on
uh sanctions uh just two comments here
one from james arnold he
it says sanctioned states find
themselves members of the sanctions club
effectively means that you build a
coalition against the west
and another point which resonates too
from wonky hills saying isn't the
underlying context for this debate the
shift in the balance
of power away from western parts now
this brings me
to the final point which i'll get you
all to comment on something
tom burgess said very on resonated with
me a lot
because he said we should see this in
the context of an undeclared and
unconventional war
with authoritarianism and for me
the history of the 21st century so far
which was meant to be the century
that saw the ultimate triumph of
democracy the first two decades have
been
the consolidation and indeed expansion
of
authoritarianism certainly the growing
confidence of authoritarianism
and of course it is authoritarian
regimes to which we take sanctions
he's absolutely right on the fact that
there is a rise in authoritarianism and
for the first time
there is very little correlation or
sorry there is a decreasing correlation
between
uh rule of law and wealth there was a
very interesting article written by
james canagasorium it was published in
medium a number of months ago
that highlighted the trend going the
other way and the real question i think
therefore for all of us has to be
where do democracies stand and what does
it mean to stand up for the rule of law
and this is exactly where some of us
have been talking about looking at gat
in 1947 and remembering that it wasn't
actually initially set up as a trade
deal it was actually
a deal to resist soviet imperialism
that used trade as a leverage and today
we need to think hard about
how do we use trade and this dan's
spoken about very powerfully already and
maya has spoken tom has spoken
differently about is using
trade as a liberator not
just as an as a an enricher and
using it to defend the values that we
think matter
the freedoms of association of
expression the liberties that we think
are important to us as citizens and
therefore using it
to actually push back on autocracies
because instead what we've done is we've
opened up trade to the autocracies
demonstrating
what perhaps our uh ancestors knew in
1947 48
was that if you trade with the soviet
common turn you end up
importing their values not just their
goods
and what really worries me about this is
that
i mean andrew of course is is right
there has been a shift
to altogether more authoritarian regimes
china is the only major economy that is
bigger now than it was
a year ago uh weirdly you would think if
you were a visitor from another planet
that in terms of the texture of daily
life that russia and china were much
more sort of liberal places than
than britain you know in terms of the
the daily restrictions and what really
worries me
is the readiness as we come out of the
lockdown
for us to abandon our traditional
freedoms
here a little bit like after as you say
after 1945
we found that powers that we'd
surrendered to the state
on a supposedly contingent basis for the
purpose of the war
were then not returned when the peace
came you know we had identity cards
until 1952 we had food rationing until
1954. we had full conscription until
1960 and when it came to the economics
we really had
the command economy in place in some
areas until the thatcher reforms indeed
in some aspects of healthcare and
education we still have bits of it
today and my worry is that coming out of
the
uh epidemic and the lockdowns we will
see
a a similar demand for the smack of firm
government that people are not just
acquiescing
in the loss of their liberties they're
demanding it and and that to me
is the biggest authoritarian danger of
all it's not just a geopolitical one
it's an internal one happening within
our countries and indeed
within ourselves but that's what hostile
state agents are pushing
here too we do know and this is where
myers point about
dirty money and the use of law is of
course entirely valid but not
totally valid because actually some of
the sanctions are genuinely sanctions
in terms of national security we know of
individuals taking
money in order to undermine us directly
in the same ways some would plant a bomb
some plant disinformation and some use
corruption
and we've always come to the end about
time but i'd just like a final word from
maya then from tom burgess maya you
first
just on on your interesting question
about authoritarian regimes two comments
one i think the point about needing
strategy and needing to study likely
impacts
it it goes even more strongly where
we're talking about trying to impose
sanctions on authoritarian regimes
because of course
the sanctions premise particularly of
targeted sanctions
is that if you impose enough pressure on
people
they will rise up and they will you know
elect a different leader or they will
start pressuring
their leaders to change policy now that
strategy needs very careful
consideration
when we're not dealing with democratic
regimes so i absolutely agree
but second and final point is do we not
think
that yes there is a rise of
authoritarian regimes
but perhaps um listening to dan hannon's
point about
the trade bill and the discussions in
parliament and indeed among the general
public
that businesses and consumers are far
more aware
of the serious abuses of human rights by
those authoritarian regimes
and might that not present an
opportunity to explore other tools
than sanctions uh which is perhaps a
debate for another evening
all right thank you for that final quick
word please from you tom
tom burgess very quickly i just say that
maybe
we should remember that one man's free
trade is another man's um
energetic embrace of dictatorship um
look at the countries we've been talking
about tonight
iran saudi arabia venezuela russia uae
what they have in common they're all
petrol states
we we um we complain about their
corruption but we
by which i mean in each of those cases
western
multinationals in whom all our pensions
are invested
pump their oil and do business with
their dictatorships and it's it's
it's actually the petro economy that
creates the worst
kleptocracies and until we turn off our
addiction to
oil that's not going to change
right thank you for that tom we'll leave
it there tom duggan
uh dan hannah maya lester tom burgess
thank you
all for being such a splendid panel
tonight on our discussion
on sanctions thanks to the initiative
for free trade for sponsoring this event
and making it possible and of course
thanks to the audience many of you out
there for watching and for sending in
your questions you can re-watch and
share
today's discussion because it's going to
be posted
on spectator tv's youtube
channel so that's spectator tv on
youtube
and you can watch it go back over the
points share it with your friends but
for all
of you watching for all of you
participating that's the end of our show
for spectator tv
for now thank you for watching goodbye